the pomegranate what is the pomegranate
chai tea white tea your deep deep so
action action
alright this right here is the first
Jaco podcast here we go I guess to start
off how did we end up here how did this
happen
I guess I have to thank Tim Ferriss for
initially having me on to his podcast
and that was via a couple people that
helped me out get on there
Kirk Bosley Peter attea and they made
some introductions and introduced me to
Tim Ferriss Tim had me on got a lot of
good feedback on that on that show and
that led to me going on to Joe Rogan so
thanks to Joe Rogan for having me on as
well and once those two things happened
and I actually got online and started
getting communicating with other human
beings online and they were asking you
know you should you should do a podcast
because it was interesting and both Joe
and Tim told me to have a podcast
because it was interesting so as I got
all that feedback which was awesome I
kind of realized I should do a podcast
so I'm sitting here my name is Jocko
Jocko willing I was if you don't know
anything about me I served 20 years in
the military retired in 2010 myself and
one of my buddies guy by the name of
lathe babban we started a company where
we
do leadership and management consulting
for businesses doing all that work
eventually got us to a situation where
we had some knowledge and kind of
aggregated some knowledge and so we put
that into a book the book came out and
been doing pretty well it's called
extreme ownership so that's who I am
now I kind of sometimes find a little
strange just to be talking and so as we
decided to put this podcast together at
one point I had done some follow-up
videos for Tim Ferriss for him to put
online and I did those with a buddy of
mine who's sitting here with me now guy
by the name of Echo Charles who is a
longtime jujitsu training partner of
mine and he does video production he's
got a company called flex point TV and
whenever I got to do something video
related he's my go-to guy and so when
this came this opportunity came about
when we were filming the videos for Tim
Ferriss and we had questions from the
internet and we were sitting there he's
filming and we were basically doing a
podcast because we were talking we're
having conversations about leadership
and about jiu-jitsu and about problems
and about everything and that kind of
rolled into when we started talking
about doing a podcast and I said hey do
you have audio equipment do you have a
recorder do you have do you have time to
sit down and hang out with me and do
this and I do he said I do I do have all
that stuff here we are so then what we
did was we took a bunch of questions
that I got from online people hit me
with all kinds of different questions
which is awesome thanks to everybody for
giving me that feedback and listening
and talking and communicating with me
that's awesome it's kind of weird
because I've never been like the most
social person in the world
not that I feel like lonely because I
never do I'm I don't care from a loan or
not so social you mean like online
social network just social definitely
not online social I mean I had zero
online presence prior to you know being
on the Tim Ferriss podcast and but but
even socially I mean I don't like hang
around with people you know that every
night I told you that like the last time
I was over here I said hey yeah I just
don't do that a lot so it's kind of
interesting to me be an online in
communicating with really thousands of
people yeah and they all and it's cool
because I'm not used to having people
that are kind of interesting the same
thing I'm interested in you know the
jujitsu the working out the want to do
better they want to get better they want
to learn more that's what I'm that's
what I want to do and it's cool to be
able to communicate with a bunch of
people that want to do the same thing
and you know I think that's what this
podcast which I know is going to evolve
into all kinds of different things but I
think the the underlying theme will be
lessons learned
you know lessons learned I want to learn
from people I want people to I want to
pass on what I've learned I don't want
people to make the same mistakes I made
I want to learn other mistakes that
people have made so I don't make them
and I think that's going to kind of be
the underlying theme here with this yeah
what about you I mean is there any thing
and your background that you would
consider to be important for people to
know hmm
above and beyond what you just said no I
think that's that's those are the
relevant points for sure that's that's
that's as we talked about doing this
that's one of the things that struck me
as you're a director you know for your
business right you're you're a film
director and you don't get in front of
the camera that's not your thing right
and so that's why I think this
interaction is good because you're you
draw things out of people that's what a
director does
yeah and I believe that's what you're
gonna be doing here
yeah yes especially when I did a lot of
the Metamora stuff that was essentially
my I was like maybe a third of the whole
job if she gets tough on her so the
jiu-jitsu players out there if you
followed metamoris at all the videos the
the what are they called lead-up videos
yeah like promo promo videos for the
matches yeah those were bounce bounce
right those were those were EKKO Charles
material right there
so you'd occasionally hear his voice in
the background with a question yeah so
speaking of questions yeah we got some
questions from the from the interwebs
yeah
what we got for the first one here we go
first question is why do you wake up
early in the morning
actually this is I kind of have the same
question because um I wake up late oh I
was in the nightclub industry for a long
time so my schedules just shifted I
still you know work out and and and work
hard for the most part during the day
but my schedules just shifted but I
think a lot of times I'm viewed as like
oh this likely riser like early risers
just to begin with kind of seem like
these disciplined you know but if you
just shift the schedule a little bit
forward you know you're up for let's say
you get eight hours see I know you get
less than eight hours sleep but let's
say the typical person eight eight hours
sleep if you get eight hours sleep but
you wake up at 4:30 versus you get the
same eight hours hours asleep same
waking um you know hour or same hours
awake and doing work and working just
sorry but you wake up at in my case noon
the crimes or whatever what's the
difference really you know whether
they're technically there is no
difference and actually I've talked to
people that they're on the night shift
right you know so they they get home at
four o'clock in the morning yeah and but
I think we both know I think we both
know what the difference is and
and I truly think you know that waking
up early now if that early means noon
because you worked until seven o'clock
in the morning or 8 o'clock in the
morning and it takes discipline to get
out of bed then I believe that there's
then that's fine but if you wake up
whenever you want and you slept for 10
hours and you're lazy getting out of bed
I think that affects your whole life in
a negative way I really do I think it's
not good
and again I know that some people are on
those schedules and I know that some
people need more sleep that's that's I
understand that there's some genetics
involved I have one of my daughters
genetically I will go to bed at 11
o'clock at night she's still awake I
wake up at 4 in the morning she's awake
so there's some genetic weirdness going
on there yeah
what um as far as hmm
getting up early let's say well how you
said okay it takes discipline to get out
of bed wouldn't that kind of indicate
that maybe you needs more sleep cuz
let's think of like what they tell what
they call the natural sleep cycle right
you go to sleep you sleep you're however
seven I think I do a seven and a half or
something like this and you naturally
wake up you got your ass but if you
gotta drag yourself out of bed doesn't
that kinda indicate you need more rest
possibly but you could be right but you
you know I always say like what do you
say psychological victory psychological
right so isn't that kind of its it's a
mental exercise right yes
so you're if that's part of your routine
to fight adversity you end up getting
better at fighting adversity whether
it's that tiredness you feel or actual
physical pain or you know and also you
sleep like if you decide to sleep more
it's because it feels good right so
right it then it's good for you
but what if you want more candy you know
you want more candy because it tastes
good but that doesn't necessarily mean
it's good in fact it's not good but I do
think that there's times that I do
definitely need more sleep and but I
don't and I also know that there's a
fine line I know when I get I know when
I get over trained I know when I get not
enough sleep and I feel it and my
workout starts going backward and my
jiu-jitsu starts going backwards and my
life starts going a little bit backwards
and then I know okay you know you you
need you need to take a day you need to
relax
sleep more maybe like wake up at like
5:00 yeah sleep into like 5:30 and you
could always tell that when we were
training fighters for the UFC you could
tell when they're when they reach their
limit when they were overtraining
it was so obvious they would just fall
apart on the mat just completely fall
apart um and you know the other thing is
I'm like making a big deal out of waking
up early there's millions of people in
the world that that's what their job is
they're a single mom and they got to
work two jobs and they're getting up at
earlier than I am and they're going to
bed later than I am because they're
supporting their family so I'm not
sitting here they're saying this is the
be-all end-all but I will say that it
definitely you it definitely has an
impact and it definitely affects the
other things in your life if you have
that discipline early in the morning it
it it will help you across the board
yeah and I always read this stuff about
creative people and this is complete
generalization but they say that
creative people tend to stay up later
and you know what usually when you stay
up later you wake up later whatever if
so it if you're mentally weak yeah so
couldn't it be kind of seen couldn't be
seen it like when my early waking is a
total lack of creativity no it seems
like here you're driven to get things
done you know get the job done get a Jon
done well no excuses right and at the
same time develop your
physical mental toughness and you know
improve yourself in these ways that it's
essentially like I want to say the
chores in life but it's like you you you
you want to get up and maximize the day
get the most work done possible right so
if you let's say okay a typical day
let's say I wake up at 8 a.m. I do my
work I get home at 5 and I you know I
kind of goof off watch some TV and maybe
I don't know maybe even go out to a bar
or something like that where although
the work is done there's no work to be
done really this far is just kind of in
a general waves way of saying it there's
no work to be done at the bar there's no
work to be done watching you know TV or
whatever so a person that lacks
discipline they're gonna it's
pleasurable the bars pleasurable you
know for you know generally speaking um
TVs vegetables so they're gonna be all
focused on that like oh I don't want to
go to bed and in face the work day the
next day I don't want to charge the work
day I want to immerse myself in the fun
part of it in the candy part of it then
they wind up going to bed late then they
wind up having to drag themselves out of
bed maybe sleep in a little bit more so
wouldn't kind of that discipline that
you talked about that applies to the
whole day not just waking up early right
so it's like a whole system so a lot of
a lot of people would like you that that
I've noticed you focus really hard on
getting stuff done and if you maximize
the time you have to get it done when
you wake up early then you can do that
more effectively and at the same time I
don't want to give the impression that
I'm living this like task-driven life
where I have every minute of the day
scheduled because because then that does
inhibit your ability to do other things
you know hibbott your it inhibits your
creativity yeah obviously but you know I
trained jiu-jitsu and I'm gonna go there
for maybe I'll just go there for 45
minutes and get some rounds in maybe
I'll be there for 3 hours and I don't
necessarily know that when I show up
because I have some flexibility in what
I'm gonna do in the day yeah the waves
are good mail go surfing you know the
but you're right that
you have to be disciplined it's not
getting out of bed is like the the
foundation of the discipline yeah and I
think it carries over everything else
because we get out of bed early and then
you work out when you get done working
out me personally I don't want to eat
junk when I get done working out I'm
like oh you know I did a good workout
I'm feeling good I'm feeling healthy
instead of eating a bowl of Lucky Charms
I'm gonna eat you know some some eggs
and bacon and something good so I agree
with you on that um yeah so mmm fears
kind of a little side note too to that
question well to me one of the things
where people ask me like what drives you
which is kind of a weird question cuz
it's a big question right I guess that's
not a weird question it's a big question
what drives like a long listed yeah
answers unknown but one of the things
that I definitely think of as a as a
driver of me is is fear and it's you
know fear of failure fear of being
overtaken you yes yes yeah what drives
me but and and this comes from I
remember being in the SEAL Teams I was
when I was a young guy in the SEAL Teams
I was very afraid of making mistakes and
looking stupid or doing dumb things and
getting a bad reputation and that fear
got me to work early and got me to
inspect my gear three more times and got
me to ask my buddy to inspect my gear to
make sure we were good to go so I think
that's what the fear is and then there's
also the fear of what the enemy is doing
and how hard are they training and are
you training harder than them and now
that I'm in the civilian world I'm
thinking okay what is what is you know
some other company doing better than
we're doing and how can we overtake them
you know and that's some weird fear and
competitiveness that you know everybody
has some people more than others you got
to balance it for sure but it's
definitely one of those things yeah yeah
sometimes that can get in the way is
we mentioned like what is that other
company doing so I knew this guy that my
brother worked with that he would be one
of those guys where he'd be really
concerned on what's the what's the
competition doing so he'd be developing
this aspect of his company and it's like
right in the middle of development there
and but he'd be painted in you know one
heir would be on the you know what's
going on with this other company and
they do some new thing or go in some new
direction that really yields a lot of
success for him
oh we got to do that we got it meanwhile
these other ideas that are solid viable
ideas are left half developed or the
resources are kind of allocated to do
this new thing and not so much the old
stuff and you know what I actually got
asked is working with a company the
other day and they said you know how
much we be focused because I said
something along these lines they said
well how much should we be focused on
what the enemy on what the competitors
are doing and should we be afraid of
them and I said actually fear is the
wrong word you shouldn't be afraid of
the enemy but you have to respect them
and I think that's the thing that gets
me out of bed in there it early in the
morning is that I respect the enemy I'm
not afraid of them but I respect them
and I'm gonna be ready to do battle with
them when design comes you know this is
kind of a side note but isn't don't you
kind of think too sometimes Werth's
you're almost like reflecting yourself
when you say you're you're you respect
and you for lack of better term fear the
enemy and what they're doing a prepare
because you know what you're doing to
prepare and it's pretty hard so you kind
of almost in the back of your mind is
thinking they're probably doing all this
too you know so it's like the more you
do the more you kind of in a bleared
subconscious way might think they're
doing they're doing the same thing you
know so it's like boom boom boom that's
never ending like it's a horse race yeah
it's an arms race someone yeah and and
if you get caught up in it to a point
like the example you just gave you I can
drive you crazy and it'll drive you to
failure you don't have to be able to
stand on your own and and say okay we're
gonna we're gonna maneuver regardless of
what the enemy is doing we're gonna make
our we're gonna make our moves yeah
next what do we got next next question
Oh actually there's a life you know and
other people sing yeah I got him I kind
of went through that yeah this is this
applies to everyone these underlying
concept okay
well then and you kind of talked about
this before mental toughness how do you
and this is another one that applies to
me where sir and you see it even in high
level certain people it's almost like
they've navigated their way through life
and to into success not really needing
that much mental toughness because maybe
they had some special attribute that
allowed them to be successful early on
and kept them success you know like
these athletes were examples yeah yeah
and you know and you you kind of notice
it when things get rough for them that's
when they break or whatever and um so I
mean I'm not saying I'm like a superior
athlete or nothing like that but it just
so happens in a lot of ways some ways
whatever um I managed to avoid
developing mental toughness up until
about maybe two years ago maybe um but
and I of course I know how mine came
about I think I mean the the main reason
was just through maturity and seen it
around me but um let's say I didn't I
wasn't surrounded by people who are
mentally tough and I didn't see the
value first and how do you just develop
mental toughness
again this is one of those things that
people asked and this was a big question
from online you know tons and tons of
people asked how do you develop mental
toughness how do you become more
mentally tough and you know you and I
did that video on it where it's like if
you want to be more mentally tough then
be tougher yeah you know in it and you
get these people that are out there that
sell courses on developing mental
toughness and you know
they're either gonna bring you into a
room and get you into some spiritual
state and say okay listen you've got to
visualize the mind of the wolf and you
are going to see through the eyes of the
wolf what does a wolf do the wolf does
not back down
he leads the pack and they're like all
this stuff right okay I'm not I don't
know not not my gig right then because
because the cool thing about mental
toughness is is it's just a simple
choice that you have to make are you
going to go through this thing that's
hard this thing that's tough this thing
that sucks are you gonna suffer through
it or are you gonna quit it's really
easy you just go okay I'm gonna suffer
through it I'm gonna deal with it
then you're mentally tough done next
question let's move on to something more
important you know what I mean yeah easy
doesn't that and maybe I'm wrong here
but that sounds like the answer coming
from someone who has doesn't sound crazy
but has the luxury of being mentally
tough so if when you're do you know do
you ever remember time that you were not
meant that you were straight-up mentally
weak do you ever remember any time
no 1996 I was an option um you know like
I'll tell you people talk about in SEAL
training they say oh everybody everybody
wants to quit at some point during SEAL
training and I literally not at all
never for one second I think I'm gonna
quit I don't want to do this anymore not
even a chance
that's ridiculous um who says that see
you'll say it's others yeah yeah
absolutely you know everyone thinks
about quitting sometimes like no and I
got plenty of rows and the SEAL Teams
that never thought about quitting yeah
take my best friends yeah they said no
you don't think about anything about
quitting yeah and so those guys are
mentally tough and okay so if you're not
mentally tough
if you view yourself as mentally weak
then you got to do things I guess push
yourself to that threshold and how do
you push yourself to that threshold you
do mentally challenging things you do
physically challenging things and you
push through yeah and then and then that
might develop your mental toughness more
right yeah you think that
it like any exercise getting the reps
you need to get those reps of hard stuff
mentally like that seminar analogy just
made that's not that doesn't seem like
that would ever work no matter if you
you're visualizing yourself as a wolf or
whatever it you're not even getting the
reps that's like saying oh I've never
played basketball ever I've never even
held a basketball but guess what we're
gonna get you we're gonna prepare you to
be good at basketball
close your eyes visualize playing
basketball and that's your reps yeah so
it probably won't work so the back to
the fear we're gonna get hammered
because all these people who like know
if you visualize you get better that's
true
like you know that experience if I don't
talk to you might be that's more of
emotions being ranked right visualize
you know winning and reacting and so um
mental toughness maybe but it won't
substitute reps I hope you're scared of
something for example that should be
like a flag or an indicator that okay I
got it let's get some reps right here
I'm scared of this you're right and that
being said like you're talking about
your body your seal buddies that never
were gonna quit right and I was
definitely never gonna quit well I
didn't have any reps going into that of
you know mentally challenging things or
whatever I mean well I did though in in
life in life that but this is this is
why I say that I'm not obviously wasn't
in SEAL Teams at all we might find that
hard to believe
um no these guys both played football
given school um they both one of them's
father was a Navy SEAL and just grow it
growing up a certain way with a certain
do like environment does make you tough
like let's say your father just not
letting you quit like you play legal Pop
Warner football and your dad's like no
you can't quit I want to quit this is
lame I'm not good or if I'm so just so
tired I'm hurt or whatever in your dad
saying no you don't quit and it just is
in your mind this is the adult and the
crazy thing about the SEAL Teams is
there's kids that grew up in you know
some rich town with very wealthy parents
and went to an Ivy League school and
they're tough and there's kids that grow
up with no dad
you know a single mom and they're tough
as hell so that theory is almost
debunked because where does that Monta
toughen come from comes from a bunch of
different places it just is interpreted
and kind of internalized in the same way
and I'll tell you where I think what
else wrong I think it comes from when a
when a human being decides that they're
gonna achieve their goals and they're
gonna go through whatever obstacles then
that's where mental toughness comes from
it is a decision that human beings make
to make it happen yeah yeah but I think
that when you know like you're doing
right now
liddie you're shirking responsibility
for mental toughness that's what you're
doing I'm trying to narrow it down
you're basically you're basically saying
right now like you didn't if you weren't
develop in a way that raised mental
toughness that is everyone else's fault
it's your fault you're not tough take me
the exact opposite of extreme ownership
of my lack of mental tough formerly
working on Oh no but I think it is a lot
of environmental factors like you become
tough because of certain environments
for sure I guess I guess we we would
need to see what happens with the people
that aren't mentally tough right because
where do they end up they end up in the
gutter they end up dead they end up in
jail they end up in bad places because
they weren't mentally tough they didn't
figure it out they didn't drive through
it and so we don't even know who those
people are what happened to them they
failed
Mortman they didn't make that decision
they didn't decide that they were going
to get out of that bad situation that
they were gonna push through that
scenario the guys that you played
football with they drove through that
those bad situations and got there no
that's how they did it they decided to
do it yeah yeah making that decision
I guess it's they would have to sort of
access a place in their mind where that
decision is final because a lot of times
people say yeah I'm gonna do this and
that's my dream and you know I'm gonna
be an architect and then when they go to
college when the beginner class is three
hours a day for five days they're uh you
know I don't know that's one thing that
the seal training does very well
is gets rid of those people because
everyone that shows up there thinks they
want to be a seal right until you know
two weeks into it and then you've got
half the guys and you end up with twenty
percent of the guys yeah everyone has
that dream when they show up there yeah
but that dream gets crushed so as I try
to imagine yourself you probably not
gonna be able to do this but imagine
yourself mentally not tough okay I don't
even want to say weak just an average
person mm-hmm you know when you know
when you get you're doing some push-ups
you hit about you know 15 you're like oh
you hit 20 or like okay I can't do
anymore so you stop doing the push-ups
and you're not the guy who's gonna get
those five extra you're not that guy is
there an exercise or an approach to just
be on the path to it did least increase
my mental your mental toughness yeah
like what the like what keep going well
yeah but I don't worry I can't keep good
yes you can I mean I can yeah yes yes
you can that's the difference
you can't you just gotta sit like okay I
remember I read the small little book
it's called mind games and um there was
this one short chapter on uh on anger
anger is like if you have anger issues
right and I never had anger issues or
nothing like that but I'd like anyone
else as young as like 23 24 you know I
get mad and think I'm better than
certain rules and when I get call out on
the rules I'd pitch it like you know
have an attitude or whatever right um so
I read this this little chapter and it
said anger issues along with other
things comes from a low self esteem
because you're real sensitive and you
react you know you're in this aggressive
way or whatever but the word low
self-esteem was like a trigger for me
so having a low self-esteem for whatever
reason I that was like an embarrassing
thing yeah so I so you know so that
could be a little trigger so you could
find little triggers in let's say you
know you're doing push-ups and you don't
do five more the fact that you don't
want to do the five more that should be
embarrassing to you ya know like if you
kind of tell yourself that that'll help
you make that decision where I'm not
going to embarrass myself right
you know so that fear of embarrassment
can get you into the mode to to want to
exercise more mental toughness you know
that trigger and at the end of the day
when you feel that weakness it's a
choice to make to overcome it it's not
that big of a deal you just suck it up
and do it let's go to the next question
you have hmm what are some key mental
and physical steps or patterns to stay
on game yes is this is one of those
questions that we got a very simple
budget very similar questions to this
what are the five key and people want to
put numbers on things especially these
days I think people's elision span yeah
yeah yeah people want to see a list of
okay if I do this yeah and I guess you
know that's it cells right what are the
five in fact they've done a bunch of
articles about life and I and they they
throw like a number on them the twelve
things the three things because people
want to believe that there's a finite
number of steps to take and also as far
as an article for consumption it makes
you feel mentally comfortable to know
that okay it's not this oh it's I know
how much I'm gonna read I know I'm gonna
breathe it twelve you know and and
that's what imma eat you know yeah uh
you know this is gonna go back to what
we've already been talking about you
know for me waking up early working out
every day taking ownership of what
you're doing and responsibilities of
things that are in your life um making
sure that you periodically throughout
the day throughout the hour maybe not
throughout the minute but that you
detach yourself from the situation that
you're in you detach yourself from it
and you look at yourself and you assess
and I think that has a huge impact and I
you know I talk about that a lot that
detachment that it is something that I
learn
in the SEAL Teams and I learned it when
bad things were happening and if you get
sucked into those bad things and you're
in them mentally emotionally and
physically
you can't assess well because you're in
the problem it's like when you're
watching a horror movie and and you know
they're like voluntarily you know oh
there's a noise down in the basement
let's go see what it is everyone that's
watching the movie that's detached from
the situation is screaming at the screen
no don't do it
the people that are there are saying yes
let's go check it out because they're
emotionally and physically and mentally
in the situation so having the ability
to detach from the support the present
from being inside your own head
being able to detach from that is it's
hugely important because it allows you
to do a real assessment of yourself and
then finally staying humble you
you can't ever think that you've got
everything figured out you've got to
constantly be saying you know what can I
do better what can I fix what am i
screwing up and people are going to give
you advice and you got to take it and
listen to it and see if it's good or not
maybe put it to the test but I think
those things you know waking up early
working out taking ownership of stuff
being able to detach and assess and
staying humble those are those are kind
of my mainstays if I had to call them
out on the list of five things that make
you better yeah yeah the ownership that
I don't I mean they're all pretty you
know these are all challenges for sure
these aren't just easy things to do but
the ownership I think that's a big key
like prison in your book what it talks
about the whole theme of the book
extreme ownership yeah where any
situation when something goes wrong when
it doesn't go perfectly or you want it
to go better it's so easy super easy
specially if you're emotionally charged
or whatever it's so easy to be like well
that guy didn't do his job or whatever
and a lot of the cases it's true that
guy didn't do his job on a conscious
last room it's and then when you do that
you don't even think
about or you don't honestly tell
yourself or think about what what you
did or what you didn't do you know or
what you did wrong you know to make that
um you know to dude what role you played
and that's why that detachment is is
critical because if you don't detach
it's very easy to be in your own head
and say well echo screwed up his part
and that's why we failed the mission
because echo didn't do his job and now
but as soon as I hear myself saying that
when I'm saying it it's okay when it's
coming out of my mouth right you know if
I see myself saying it then I know that
I've yeah I've gone the wrong way I know
that I've made a mistake yeah and what's
interesting is when you when you and
it's something you can do like right now
you don't have to get trained in it you
can start practicing taking ownership of
everything you possibly can literally
right now and what I found and and
really liked about it is that it works
not just like with business works with
everything relationships with you
friends relationships with your wife or
girlfriend or boyfriend whatever all
that it works amazing in all those
situations so it apply it's really kind
of like a staple for life you know like
a way to conduct yourself just in life
yeah and that is that is why that is why
that became the title of the book
because that is the underlying
characteristic that helps people in
their life and I mean that means as a
leader of course obviously in a pressure
situation obviously in a business
obviously but you're right and it it
takes transitions across the board to
life and and it makes you successful
across the board when you take ownership
of everything no doubt about it
mmm so at age 44 you get out of bed bust
your ass like the next mission is around
the corner what drives you actually kind
of talked about that kind of that fear
of the enemies preparation yeah but what
do you know you know this is one of
those things that
when when people start talking about a
war and what war does to people and you
know nowadays we're hearing and we see
more and we know more about what war
does to people's minds and obviously it
is it can have some some extremely
negative impacts on people and there's a
lot of veterans right now that are that
are suffering that are having a hard
time and
I think for me when I think about what
drives me it's an extremely powerful
force that's driving me today and that
is that I served with guys that
sacrificed their lives so that we could
be here so that I could be here so that
we could have freedom so that I could
have never mind freedom so that I could
be here alive and when you think about
that when you think about this gift this
gift that you've been given to come back
to America and be free and have a life
and have Liberty and be free for the
pursuit of happiness you think about
that gift it's the most beautiful thing
anyone could ever give you it's been
given you it's been given to me and I
will not squander that gift and I will
make every day count as I remember those
guys that gave that gift to me
yeah hey funny how like you know how you
kind of get a glimpse of certain
people's life and how they how they
behave and how they act what their
routine and schedule is and when you
like keep just hearing that and you've
said that before and and you've even
kind of said that to me before
and it kind of reminds you how much you
all reminds me how much I'm not doing
you know in you know how if you get free
money it it almost means less right than
if you earn it
you know so I think a lot of times when
you don't do a lot or you know maybe you
know you haven't served or something
like that it's almost like free money
and you've been exposed to earning that
money in real sense
yep so that's boom that's constantly
just in your nature now and then you
know other people they do have to be
reminded you know cuz you know what a
powerful reminder because every day and
I would say every minute of every day
I'm thinking about those guys mmm
and that that that's uh that definitely
pushes me and I don't wanna let those
guys down yeah
so in regards to the military you know
officers entering SpecOps or other elite
scenarios what advice would you have for
them you know this is again this is one
of those questions that's come up and I
get this a lot because a lot of people
that listen to Joe Rogan a lot of people
that listen to Tim Ferriss they're
younger folks and they they're they
might be stepping in a leadership
position for the first time and so we
definitely got a lot of a lot of
questions from military guys that are
getting promoted they're going to be
promoted into leadership positions and
we get a lot of younger people that are
stepping into the business world and
they're stepping into leadership roles
for the first time in those situations
and I think that um the and I would tell
both the Special Operations folks and
the folks in the business world the same
thing because as if anyone's listened to
me at all or heard anything that I say
or read the book the leadership
principles do not change regardless in
business or in battle the leadership
principles stay the same and so if
you're new and you're up-and-coming what
do you do how do you step up into that
role number one be humble I know it's a
theme I sound like a broken record but
you everybody knows everybody's seen
that cocky guy that walks in and thinks
they're gonna run everything and you
just instantly disrespect that person so
how do you overcome that you come in and
you be humble you respect people you
know you respect people regardless of
what rank you are regardless of whether
you're you're making a ton more money
than someone else it doesn't matter you
treat everybody with respect you treat
them with respect and they're gonna
respect you you listen to them it means
so much when when when one of your
people comes and talks to you and you
sit down and say okay let me take some
notes on what you're saying that means
so much to them and sometimes people
forget that you know they forget what it
means to look up and see the boss man
they might blow a guy off or you know
hey I don't have time for you right now
you gotta listen to people because what
you're trying to do in a leadership
position and this is a word that I've
only recently become comfortable saying
the word is relationships you are truly
and that's what that's what business is
that's what that's what life is
that's what business is that's what
combat is that's how you lead people in
combat in business you have
relationships with them life and I talk
about this all the time you know sure I
can give you an order if you if you're
below me in rank and you might do it
some of the time but you're not gonna
the people that really follow you that
you have a relationship with you those
guys will do anything for you
the guys that I that I worked with the
guys that worked for me were my
subordinates they do anything for me and
you know what I would do anything for
them don't do anything for those guys
the guys that were in my task unit guys
were awesome they were awesome guys and
I would do anything for those guys I
would give them anything anything and
they would do the same for me why
because we had relationship we that was
what we had it wasn't because I would
order them to do something that doesn't
work so you got to build those
relationships and how do you build
relationships how do you build
relationships then you build
relationships by doing those things by
respecting people by being humble by
listening by telling them the truth by
having integrity and telling people the
truth you can't lie to people and I'm
Eli is a strong word because you know I
don't think people are generally lying
to each on a regular basis but people
people use half-truths and they you know
they shadow things and you can't do that
and people see right through it and even
if they don't know what the truth is
they know they're not getting the truth
right so you know I I was always with my
guys okay here's what's going on here's
the problem here's what we screwed up
here's what we need to do better here's
the pressure I'm under from higher
quarters here's why I'm under this
pressure I'm not sugarcoating it I'm not
trying to set something up to be
different than what the reality is if
I'm getting told to do something that I
don't believe in okay now this is a
tough one if I'm getting told us to do
something I don't believe in I'm not
gonna go tell my guys hey I don't
believe in this and we're gonna do it
anyways no no no if I don't believe in
it I gotta figure out why we're doing it
and I'm gonna say okay boss I do not
understand why we're doing this I don't
see how this gonna help us win the
battle so so you need to explain this to
me so I can explain it to my guys
because I'm not gonna go lie to him I'm
also not going to go down there and say
hey we're doing this anyways or or I'm
not going to send people to do things
that I don't believe it we're all trying
to win the war my boss is trying to win
the war I'm trying to win the war my
guys are trying to win the war so my
boss isn't gonna tell me do something
that doesn't make sense and doesn't
isn't logical to win the war so I should
believe in it and if I don't then I
should question him and those are those
are the things that allow you to build
relationships and we'll the topic of the
night again ownership you know if you're
if you take ownership when there's
problems and you get them solved and
then when things do go right you pass
that past the reward and the credit onto
your boys then you that that also helps
you build those relationships that's
what I would tell a new leader in the
business world work hard you know if I
should have said that ones like number
one work hard yeah that's another thing
that whole that whole answer with what
you just said applies there's another
thing that applies to everything yep
even you say as a leader you know in a
mmm you know with the chain of command
and all all your guys that works with
your kids your friends or just even in
general like you know at the gym if
you're if I used to work with this guy
and men he is the nicest guy he was the
nicest guy he'd always have compliments
but you know kind compliments that are
kind of too good like mehnat I don't
know let's say I'm wearing a new shirt
man that shirt is [ __ ] awesome
and and then my buddy I've never been
told you're gonna have to come up with a
different well but he would do that kind
he would say you know give you
compliments right but just overdo it
little bit too much just a little bit
just to step outside of the room with it
being believable yeah so the kind where
you get man that's awesome
and then he bought you know walk away
whatever the nightclub and he come back
man that is an awesome shirt you know
it's hard to believe given what I know
about this person that you're that into
your shirt right just maybe some you see
and that would be a thing if there was
other indicators right so it's it's a
whole persona so it takes that it takes
you being consistent and all these
things that you're saying honest and in
really consistent about it so the point
of your story is that you didn't build a
relationship with a great because you
didn't trust him yes exactly right so
you know when you're saying tell the
truth you know if it's if it's bad you
gotta tell the truth you're not gonna
this guy literally it's almost like he
would only want to tell you good news so
it could be like he could it's almost
like you had this feeling like even if
he hated my shirt I thought it looked
back or something like that um he would
he would say oh that's a that's a cool
shirt and you know this is important
this brings me to another point and that
is um balance and I talk about balance
all the time because all these things
have to be balanced and when you're
talking about truth right now you have
to be tactful you know being being
truthful and being honest does not give
you permission to be a jerk it doesn't
do that and so there's a difference
between you know oh I don't like echo
shirt so I'm gonna say dude that's an
ugly shirt right and just like in when
you're working with you know
subordinates and they screw something up
you know you're in it you know that was
a horrible job you you you let me down
no no okay
hey well first of all you want to take
ownership of it obviously didn't give
you good enough guidance but the bought
the point that I'm trying to make is
being honest with people there's people
that are blunt honest leaders and
everyone hates them because they're so
blunt they don't have any tact they
don't they don't
maneuver they don't use jujitsu they
don't they don't think and they don't
assess the whole situation and they
think that if if I tell echo you know if
I want echo to use method a and echos
used to move using method B echo might
have a personality that if I go up and
say hey use method a now I'm being blunt
I'm being Frank
what does echo say - that echoes like
dude I've been doing this a lot longer
than you I'm not gonna do method a I'm
sticking my method that's real I need to
get you know so you've got to you've got
to influence people you've got to be a
chess player not a checkers player and
so don't confuse being honest with being
blunt and on tactful and a jerk you have
to do jujitsu and for anyone that's
listening that doesn't do jiu-jitsu
jiu-jitsu is a very nuanced game where
you're constantly trying to set things
up and shape the situation it's not like
boxing and boxing I'm trying to punch
you you're trying to punch me in jujitsu
you're trying to maneuver on the other
person you're trying to get better
positions on them you're trying to flank
them and come in from a different
direction that they didn't expect that's
what the art of leadership is anyone
could go through a list of hey here's
what you guys screwed up on the mission
1 2 3 4 5 fix it that guy's not going to
be respect as a leader even though he's
truthful and an honest and blunt it's
not gonna get him where he needs to be
there's a whole nother game playin and
yeah yeah and it's and it's and it's
dealing with egos and it's dealing with
personalities that's really what it
boils down to everyone has different
personalities and learning how to be a
craftsman that knows what tools to use
with what different types of wood that's
what being a leader is hmm yeah
if leadership was do these next seven
things and you'll be a great leader I
wouldn't have a book and I wouldn't have
a business because everyone would be a
great leader there is an art to it it is
a it is a very difficult thing to do
it's simple there's simple steps you
know be honest yo show integrity take
ownership well there's those simple
steps but at the same time there
credibly nuanced and that's what makes
it challenging and that and that's what
makes it so rewarding as well that is
absolutely what makes it so rewarding
yeah
people don't people who don't take
account of Italy uh don't take
accountability right blaming everyone
else um how do you deal with people like
that
yes and I mean prep personally how do
you deal with them cuz I guess where
would it be the same way as you would
professionally personally professionally
it's all the same these are they give
these are questions that we get asked on
a regular basis and we definitely got a
lot of ma - you know these how do you
feed how do you deal with people that
don't take accountability how do you
deal with leadership that doesn't get
the message that you are communicating
right so just so we can both understand
very out of the gate here both those
questions what do both those questions
do what this question both these two
questions they have something in common
how do you deal with people people that
don't take accountability and people
that don't have the message that you're
communicating you're not taking
accountability it's you're blaming these
people you're blaming them for not
taking accountability you're blaming
them for not understanding your message
right whose fault is that you're only
taking extreme ownership that's your
hundred percent of the time so if I'm a
leader and my people aren't taking
responsibility for their actions
that's not their fault it's my fault I
have not shown them how to lead properly
I haven't shown them how to take
accountability and how do you do that
hey you know if echo does something
wrong I don't go echo you screwed this
up
I say echo this went wrong it's my fault
that I didn't explain it to you well
enough I'm not gonna talk to you baby
but like hey you know what do we do
wrong how do we not how do we how do we
make this happen you know you got to
take ownership of it and that's what
does that make echo do that makes echo
say oh you know what
no it was my fault you know what I mean
so both those questions how do i how do
I solve those problems I of them that's
number one
number two what do I do because to take
ownership of them isn't quite enough
here we need we need to be smarter than
that we again we need to play chess so
what I always try and do from a
leadership perspective is I always try
and understand the perspective that
other people have this kind of goes to
detach me I gotta detach from my own
head and I got to see it from their
perspective so I can understand what
does it look like from echos viewpoint
what does it look like from my most
junior guy that's not doing what I want
to do why isn't he doing what is he
singing from his perspective what is it
okay my boss doesn't understand what I'm
trying to communicate to him guess what
what is his perspective how do I detach
from my own head see what his
perspective is because once I see his
perspective I can adjust it so it's very
important to try and understand other
people's perspectives and it's usually
not that hard
people are often you know pretty easy to
read and as soon as you leave your own
head and get into theirs you'll see how
you can change the scenario and make
them understand it better
so those are two big pieces yeah that's
that's another one that's that applies
to everything and how you were saying
these are simple steps but simple but
not as easy yeah commands to get out of
your own head
and you know it it's hard it definitely
is challenging especially in these
pressure situations rush situations
where emotions are involved and you
start getting fired up people are
yelling or there's you know capital at
risk or jobs at risk or lives at risk
it's it's definitely hard to do that and
guess what those situations where it's
hardest to do are the most critical
times where you need to step back
calm down step outside your own head
don't see the emotions let your ego go
understand other people's perspectives
that's when you need to do it the most
yeah
oddly enough
so what would you say is your most
difficult day in the military or can you
even single one out and how did it
affect you or shape you or you know put
you forward you know the time I was in I
was in the SEAL team for 20 years and it
was awesome it was I became and called a
job because it was so fun and surrounded
by great guys and even overseas in Iraq
I was having an absolute fantastic time
the whole time obviously those were the
best days of my life being a combat
leader in a combat situation that's what
I wanted to do my whole life and when I
was there I knew that and those were the
best days of my life and encompassed
inside those great days are obviously
the worst days of my life and no doubt
the worst days of my life's were the
days when my guys got killed and markley
first SEAL killed in Iraq Maiki Mansour
second seal killed in Iraq was
posthumously awarded the Medal of Honor
for jumping on a grenade to save three
of her other teammates and Ryan job who
was severely wounded blinded in both
eyes after he was shot in the face who
made it home and eventually after his
22nd surgery to repair the damage that
would have done to his head and face he
died as well and
the day that was the absolute worst was
when I came home from deployment and I
didn't have those guys with me
and
II I was coming home to my family to my
kids to my wife and they weren't
and how it affected me as far as my
military career goes I truly understood
what was at stake in combat and when I
took over training out on the west coast
I was obsessed with making the training
as realistic as possible and getting the
guys that were going overseas to Iraq
and Afghanistan getting them as prepared
as they could humanly possibly ever be
to be in these worst-case scenarios and
I remember you know I remember we'd set
up these scenarios that were very very
difficult I mean unbelievably difficult
like you were gonna have massive
challenges and I remember I'd see a guy
like for instance in an urban
environment training I see a guy
standing in the middle of street you
know like what you would not want to do
if you were in Ramadi in 2006 and I'd
see and I would I would get this feeling
less sick to my stomach feeling because
like in the back of my mind I'm waiting
for rounds to start hitting the ground
and kill this guy or wound him and I
would you know get fired up and you know
explained to him listen you cannot you
got to move from cover to cover don't be
standing out her in the little street
wires there's there's no cover fire
going on you know and that's that's how
it affected me as far as my military
career and how it affected me in my life
you know I've already told you how it
affected me those are those guys I'm
trying to honor them by by living the
best life I can and taking advantage of
the freedom that they blessed me with
so
I'm going to go to the another question
from online here hmm how'd you come to
know the darkness and how does it
motivate you dealing with it and using
the light to win this is Star Wars
question kind of embarrassed but cuz
you're talking about the darkness and
the light I don't know about it it's um
it's definitely uh something that i
something that i it's definitely
something that i think about you know
and i the world is an evil place and
there's a lot of evil in the world
there's pain there suffering there's
disease there's evil there's war I mean
there's bad things in the world and
sometimes people ignore those things and
and you know we talked about this with
with Jill Rogen quite a bit you know we
we can live in a bubble here in America
whether almost is no pain and there
almost is no suffering and they're
almost as no violence in their own
almost as no evil and for some reason
I've always stepped outside that bubble
and looked and seen what the rest of
world is like and so I think that's a
counter to what a lot of people believe
the world is like and so for me that
darkness is always present it's always
there and at the same time there is
light and there is people that are
incredibly generous that sacrifice
greatly that give everything they have
to serve other people doctors you know
nurses firefighters there's all these
people teachers I mean there's just
people that do all they can to help
other people
and and to do good in the world um and
so I think that just that's what I try
and balance in my mind and and I don't
want people to think that I sit around
and brood all day about the darkness you
know because I don't you know I mean I I
love to have a good time and laughing
and you know smile and I want to do that
you know but I also in those moments I'm
definitely thinking that you know we're
lucky to be here yeah and doesn't that
make like you know I don't know a day
where you're just kind of cruising or
whatever and you know looking for a
laugh or whatever and I mean hang with
your friends or whatever doesn't don't
those days seem a lot more enjoyable
when you do have the darkness in mind
you know we're even I mean you know you
have kids so let's I don't know your
daughter spill some milk and laughs
about it right if you know what the rest
of the world is like that's gonna seem
almost enjoyable that's funny that's
cute you can recognize your all the
great things about that little moment
it's a lot easier to recognize the great
things about that look exactly if you
understand if you think that yeah the
worlds are hunky-dory and milk never
supposed to be spilt and you know all
this stuff and everything's perfect and
sweet and that's kind of your mindset
and all they still the milk that's a
disruption and you're like yeah that's
your dot but yeah that's my tart sure
you know I see my daughter every single
day spilled the milk how to disrupt you
know so it's kind of that debt you know
without hardship there can be no
pleasure kind of contrast that kind of
it brought out more huh no doubt about
it
no doubt about it um I saw every once in
a while you'll hear people going man
like this country's going like violence
or whatever you know likes going down
the [ __ ] or all this stuff and you
could if you think about it
and let's say your normal day maybe not
you but improbably you to your normal
day
if you let's say you got up you worked
out you went to the store like let's say
oh I want to get a pomegranate white tea
it 70 left and you go and you're
standing in line and the guy in front of
you gets into a heated argument with a
cash guy the cashier and it starts
swearing swearing at him and say oh you
I don't like these prices yelling just
yelling Adam and then he's a get out of
here and you know anything's right screw
this place using profanity gets in hard
speeds away right didn't break any laws
just that happen right in front of you
you I would we would probably remember
that for a while all it was was a
yelling that's all it was no violence no
laws being broken no no no physical
anything just the argument between two
people and some disrespects I'm just
respected exactly you'd remember that
that would that would be a significant
incident in your day that's how good the
world is or your environment that's how
good this country is you know of course
you know that we're talking about a
spectrum here you don't certain areas
gonna be a little worse but keep in mind
like in our environment I know here in
San Diego that's essentially how it is
most of the time if you see two people
almost get in a fight that's a
significant event right there yeah so
overall I would say there's a lot of
light around here there's a lot of lies
you know so I think that if you think
about it and you've been exposed to it
so Dan you can really have a have an
accurate perspective um the light is
very noticeable you know if you can if
you can constantly have that contrast
and know it no there's no doubt about
that um when is when DC ego get in the
way like when is it most prevalent do
you think it's so prevalent everywhere
and this is a when when I saw this
question I immediately thought of
this guy whose ego just completely got
in the way and he was able to fix it on
this particular situation and it was me
so so this is actually a funny story
this guy so we we started working with a
company and the company had a pretty
young CEO and he was a super smart guy
and he had played football in college a
sweet d1 football player just a pretty
badass guy he's super smart super
articulate and when I met him I like
there was a little tension between him
and me there was a little something
there's a little tension and I'm looking
at the sky and I'm like this guy really
thinks he's a badass and and so when we
go through a meeting and go through
another meeting and there's just this
tension I'm going yeah this guy's
definitely he's got issues he's got
problems looking this guy and I can feel
it come from him that he's thinking the
same thing
are you sure you think of the video I'm
sure that doesn't you look at here again
I'm positive just thinking the same
thing and I'll tell you how how I know
that
so as I'm sit there so we actually did
did did like a whole like two days with
this company and then we were coming
back and the next time we came back I go
you know what's gonna be like the time I
have this again with this guy this
[ __ ] I come back and sure enough
there it is I see him he's like looking
at I'm looking at him and he's looking
at him and there's tension and all of a
sudden I so I detached from the
situation and I looked at myself and I
said Jocko you're an idiot because here
I was and what was I thinking I was
jealous of the guy mmm or yeah
intimidated or jealous or whatever the
words threatened I I was jealous I think
was jealous because he was he was a
young guy that had been very successful
made a ton of money
we went to a big school and played ball
and all that stuff and he had done all
this stuff and what was he thinking
looking at me he was looking at me
thinking oh this guy he was a seal and
he was your jiu-jitsu guy and he's a
badass and and both of us were basically
envious of the other one in some way and
really what it was I guess envious the
wrong wrong word our egos both of our
egos had had impacted and so as soon as
I realized that I I was like BAM I
immediately changed my attitude and I
was like and in the next opportunity I
had you know learn a break or something
I was like you know what after working
with you a couple days here you're
awesome I said what you've done is
badass to be your age and be dominating
a company like this and have raised it
together and built it that's awesome and
made a ton of money I love that and
that's just badass man I I have nothing
but respect for you and what you've done
and I actually want to learn from you
while I'm here
mm-hm and immediately it was like a
force field came down and he said to me
you know what no matter what I've done
in my life it's never gonna be what
you've done and and and and after that
we were bros but I had to recognize the
ego in the situation mine and his and I
just had to disarm it and then it was
all gone so it's a story about ego my
big ugly ego and again ego you know you
go drives people tomorrow what makes
people want to be successful and it has
a lot of positives to it but it can
definitely get in the way
yeah to them you recognize that story
right be like you you realize like how
that happens yeah oh yeah Philippe
especially when you can see their men I
can't remember the exact words how they
plan I forget even where I saw it but it
was it you're threatened typically by
something along the lines of if someone
is a like capable or if there's these
things that people have to be
in your eyes that make some threatening
to you so wouldn't it kind of put real
loosely when you see someone who is
essentially you you're gonna feel Brett
and it doesn't have to be you like
they're the same height as you're the
same racing and not at there's some kind
of equivalency that India and all that
intimidates your ego yeah so if you get
someone who's little you're kind of
built um like you for example if
someone's kind of built boom that's one
thing if he's around your same age it
kind of depends because it can be as if
they're a functioning able adult put it
that way
Em's a guy kind of your bill
boom-boom-boom those are all these other
things that it's limitless like dogs and
it's yes funny doesn't be like it
happened like specially at the gym when
someone a new guy walks in and he's kind
of built watch everyone's that eyes go
to do you know yeah ears pop up yes
flank and yeah that goes everywhere
business world you know the girls have
it bad man my audience fun no nice I
don't know would they see other girls
you know yeah that that yeah it's fine
um do you do you want to go uh do you
want to go over these as well you know
what I'm trying I from myself coming
from myself okay but Nene what were you
gonna say
proceed with your questions okay so um
conspiracy theories right uh you know
how you know people that will they'll go
into the concern conspiracy RAM trials
are early and 9/11 the inside job or
recently the the San Bernardino
shootings like that was a you know what
they're saying like the government
staged it or whatever um do you ever
engage with people about conspiracy
theories I haven't engaged with anyone
about conspiracy theories so do you when
you hear it like a new for example K if
you're you're not really on Facebook but
um we'll just say online you can see
people expressing their opinions
about the conspiracy theories that they
believe it mm-hmm and they're really
over us let's say for example someone
expresses their feelings about a certain
conspiracy theory to you D on what level
do you entertain that not very much just
kind of across the board yeah not very
much across the board I'm not trying to
convert people and make people think
things and and and I'm definitely not
going to expend a bunch of energy diving
into things that are not worth diving
into yeah um you know with conspiracy
theories you can tie anything to
anything if you want to I mean any major
global occurrence that's happening will
be tied into the rest and it into some
way to Kraft macaroni and cheese I mean
there will be a connection to Kraft
macaroni and cheese if you dig deep
enough there'll be an employee there'll
be a purchase there'll be a plant
there'll be a farm they'll be a there'll
be a sales there'll be a stock there'll
be some connection between that and
whatever incident that happened on the
globe and if you want to formulate those
and tie those pieces together you can do
it because the world is connected and
when people say oh this corporation was
involved in some way with this incident
in this war taking place you say well
yes you know there are big giant
corporations that have huge interests
around the world and they're going to
protect those interests and that's what
the world is made of so I don't do a lot
of debating about
conspiracy theories no there you go
somebody sent me a link to like a a
video about 9/11 and I clicked on it and
it was something like eight hours long
the video the video was eight hours long
about you know and and I just thought
well okay you know again if you want to
you can connect anything to anything if
you want to that's the way the that's
the way the global world is the global
economies it's the way things are did
you watch the whole video I I watched
until I saw it's at eight hours then I
know I know we got some questions
questions about blood meridian i think
that those that book which is obviously
a very powerful book it's i think we got
to save that for the next podcast i know
we got quite a few questions about chris
kyle and you know people want to know if
I knew Chris if I worked with Chris and
the answer is yes Chris Kyle was the
lead sniper and point man in Charlie
platoon which was life baboons he was
the the officer in charge of a platoon
and that was in task unit bruiser which
I was a commander of so we absolutely
you know knew Chris and worked alongside
Chris
Lafe was on every mission for all
practical purposes that that Chris was
on and you know I couldn't laugh and I
spoke at Chris's memorial service and
Cowboy Stadium I mean it's so yes we we
know Chris very well and at some point
will will
I'll get layfon here and we'll we'll
talk about Chris some and tell some
stories about Chris that would you know
provide a perspective that may not have
been seen in the the portrayals that
have been given so far so I think we we
need to hold off on that one and maybe
just do one more question here do you
have any friends that aren't neat well
that aren't military and that are not
jiu-jitsu or MMA death yes I do I do
mostly musicians I should say both the
musicians surfers I got some I got quite
a few friends I bet surf I surf and out
here in California and and I got some
friends that play music and you know we
rock and roll yeah and that's something
that I actually forgot I knew you
thought saying you knew that you surf
but that you play guitar yes would you
like part of a band there's something
yeah um I was I was in bands my whole
life when I was growing up and I was a
kid yeah it it's funny like a lot of
successful people or people who are you
know they always have all these skills
and what's interesting is that like
surfing and playing guitar like that's
not easy you know it's not I mean I'm
not gonna not gonna talk bad about golf
but Golf is seems like oh yeah you just
go out and you play golf and sure some
people they get good and great you know
and it is it's fun and stuff but it's
not like surfing you know and surfing is
fun and me and really this very there's
a little bit more of a physical
challenge yes more foot in a challenge
and a challenge that it shows when you
are good at surfing or not good at
surveyed shows you know oh seemingly I
know I guess that's just my opinion but
it's always interesting that like to
play the guitar sure yeah
black belt in jujitsu what's interesting
is too is um and these are some other
like I know some guys that are surfers
and musicians and artists and
I want to bring some of those guys and
talk to them because they have different
outlooks on things and how to get good
and what kind of discipline it takes and
what drives them I mean you know like
you said surfing is challenging surfing
is cold it's wet it's dark it's it's
sketchy sometimes guys that do that
their whole life until they're 70 or 80
years old that's pretty awesome yeah um
yeah went on for at UM so so one more
okay yeah last question will the time
you wake up in the morning and why do
you wake up at that time and what do you
think about well we we talked about what
time I wake up in the morning but I
think this last question is here what do
you think about before you go to bed at
night and and really to me I mean to
kind of close this out is the last
question of what do you tell people or
what do I think is most as a helpful
kind of lessons learned to close on and
I think one conversation I had with a
with one of my one of my guys who was
just a complete awesome
warrior named JP JP how you doing
brother out there um when we were going
through training to get ready for Iraq
and when you're when you're going
through SEAL training you get you learn
you learn all this information and they
teach you all these things and you layer
them on top of your brain and there's
layers and layers and layers of these
tactics and techniques and procedures
and the layers can get so thick that you
lose contact with the ground and so we
were out in training
and I was looking at JP who is a stud
and it was one of those situations where
we're out in the desert but there's
rocks and there's little shrubs and all
that and he was standing up in the wide
open because he was staying in the
formation of the patrol the way that he
was taught in the way that he had been
indoctrinated is one of those layers as
you're here and you stand here and this
is your field of fire and you watch this
area but what he'd forgotten was that
you're standing in the middle of an open
area
don't stand there move to this little
rock and then move to this little shrub
and then move this little so that way if
a bad guy looks he's not going to see
you and if he does see you he starts
shooting you have a place to hide and I
said to him I said JP my brother he's
like what's up sir I said hey man if you
were ten years old right now and we were
out playing army out here would you
stand in the middle of this open trench
right here would you stand here and he's
like no I said well where would you
stand
he said I'd go over there to that rock
right there and I'd get behind that I
said so your ten year old brain is doing
better job moving from cover to cover
then your twenty three-year-old brain
and I said listen your instincts you
know what the right thing to do is you
know what it is do it and he did and it
was amazing and and I think that people
you me everyone people listening people
that communicate with us you know what
the right thing to do is you know what
it is you know it's be discipline you
know what's work hard you know it's put
your ego in check you know these things
you just got to do you just got to do
I think we close it out with that yeah
so um thanks to everybody for joining we
had a bunch of people on uh on periscope
that was pretty cool to watch and we'll
see how this one goes and we'll do some
more in the near future yeah I like the
idea that people are really engaged with
you online and and they'll ask you
questions right and you'll essentially
confirm like check the ice attack that's
a good question kind of thing you you're
engaging I think that's a good thing cuz
these are real questions it's not like
questions and we just thought up um know
got some great questions yeah so I I
would say - yeah encourage that - you
know for people if they're wondering
about stuff because this is in my
experience everything that you've even
said before this and and even just stuff
you said to me personally or what it's
all like really useful stuff and not
just in business it it applied the
concepts applied it pretty much
everything in life functioning in life
if you can function with these concepts
you're getting you're gonna do good
it'll be kind of on you if you don't
nothing to take that extreme militia
awesome alright thanks everybody for
joining it
we'll talk to you next time out here